what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
okay so on the whole when it comes to
Green Lantern stuff I usually try to
avoid talking about things that happen
later on or happen you know in the
future from where we're currently at and
the reason why is because continuity is
so tight-knit when it comes to Green
Lantern they usually don't have the
ability to steer away without getting
sort of thrown into this whole great big
huge mess of things and so this will be
one of the only occasions where we do
that but in this video we're gonna be
talking about the origin of the Indigo
tribe now the origin of the Indigo tribe
is kind of interesting because this is a
Lantern Corps that when it first popped
up was incredibly mysterious they made
their appearance as part of blackest
night and it was something like four or
five years after they debuted that DC
finally gave us an origin story now
their origin is done in two phases the
first is the actual origin and the
second is their first appear so we're
actually gonna take it out of order here
what we're gonna do is we're gonna jump
to an existing story that was taking
place
in 2012 called the secret of the Indigo
tribe and it was written by Jeff Jones
now again this is a great big larger
story involving the entirety of the
Indigo tribe and there are things that I
don't want to spoil for what happens
later on what we really need to focus on
here is their origin in and of itself
and so what this does is it basically
kind of picks up with Hal Jordan you
know basically looking for questions
about the Indigo tribe you know a very
mysterious very enigmatika
what this does is it leads him to a man
by the name of Metro Mo at least I think
that's how you pronounce it this guy is
basically like the voice of the Indigo
tribe and so the idea is that he
effectively gives how Jordan this kind
of explanation on who the Indigo tribe
are but even then it's not a
tried-and-true origin in terms of what
we're used to for those of the guys who
were new to - DC comics or comic books
in general origin stories are usually
told exactly how you would think they
are in the sense that it's basically a
step-by-step guide in terms of how
things progress Superman for example
Krypton was coming to an end
Superman was sent away on a spaceship he
arrived on earth he was adopted by John
and Martha Kent he eventually became an
employee at the Daily Planet he was
Superman he had all these experiences
that went into making him who he was but
it was a step-by-step thing it was a and
then B and then C and then P and this
instance is not that way instead what
we're basically told is that there was a
planet called knock at least as they
call it and it's one of those double
meaning things in the sense that when
indigo remembers the Indigo tribes say
knock it can mean compassion be with you
or it could simply just be them
referring to their own planet but
regardless of what it is what ended up
happening is somewhere along the line
this sort of you know warring group from
you know another planet showed up on not
with the intention of taking its
inhabitants and then just you know using
them as slaves or whatever the case may
have been the result was that when all
this took place the Green Lantern of
that sector a guy by the name of a band
sewer
had basically intervened now again we've
talked about avid sewer over the course
of our run so far in the sense that it
all really just kind of goes back to him
and that's the nature of this it's one
of the reasons why I figured now was a
great time to do it just because of the
fact that this feeds into the whole
blackest night prophecy now the idea was
that with Aven soar basically showing up
and then defending these guys who were
being you know attacked by these slavers
more or less this ultimately led to Adam
sewer alongside Emmitt Romo discovering
what was basically just this well of
compassion is the best way that it's
described but what they began doing was
basically forging weapons and when they
use these weapons they realized that
these weapons had an impact on the
people they were being used on and those
individuals who were cut stabbed
whatever the case may have been
basically shifted their entire mentality
and then adopted the form of compassion
for shorten on a time now what this did
is it basically allowed Adams sewer to
realize that what this was doing was it
was allowing people to tap into the
compassion aspect of the emotional
spectrum remember if you're new to all
this the emotional spectrum is kind of
like this governing thing that exists
all throughout the DC Universe that as
long as there are people that feel
compassion as long as there are people
who feel rage who feel fear who have the
willpower the ability to overcome fear
those aspects of the emotion will exist
so long as life exists the emotional
spectrum will exist because beings will
feel all those different emotions at
some point over the course of their life
the result of this is that Abin soar
began the process of basically creating
indigo rings now this coincided with
another event that was going on in the
life of a bean store basically looking
to the future when we first picked up
our whole run on Geoff Johns Green
Lantern we talked about the secret
origin of how jordan's so on and so
forth one of the things that we
discussed
was the prophecy of blackest night and
it was this huge you know piece of
information this huge story that was
basically coming later on down the line
but the seeds of this story were planted
all the way back maybe some three years
before it ever actually took place and
everything that happened between the
time that Jeff Jones first took up green
lantern with the original Green Lantern
rebirth story going up into blackest
night was all designed to lead into
blackest night it was all just this
massive you know three-year long prelude
or however long it was and so what we
ended up finding out is that back when
Adam Sewer had first encountered
Atrocitus who was basically the person
who created the Red Lantern Court when
Atrocitus told Adam soar that he had
looked into the future he had seen the
war of light the war of the Lantern
course basically the prophecy of
blackest night that the dead would
essentially take over all things in
existence that what avid saw began to do
was build up an army for himself now
this army was not designed specifically
to combat blackest night' instead the
idea is that somewhere along the line
the guardians of the universe which are
the ones who created the Green Lantern's
would get in the way of a dance or
that's exactly what we've seen play out
so far the idea here is that when the
prophecy of blackest night' basically
became this common knowledge thing most
of the guardians basically all of them
except for ganthet and sayd had
basically said that's nonsense
that's a fear tactic and so the idea was
that there was no legitimacy to this
whole blackest I think now eventually
ganthet and sayd had basically stepped
aside from the other guardians of the
universe and said well maybe this
blackest night might be true and if it
is we need to be prepared hence the
reason why they created the Blue Lantern
Corps but the idea of the Indigo tribe
is that for for Aven sore looking to the
horizon and seeing that the guardians of
the universe are basically these really
old people who were just stuck in their
ways
he wanted to make sure that if the
guardians of the universe got in his way
he'd be able to overcome them
hence the basis behind the Indigo Tron
the issue with this is that a person can
only really feel compassion when they
have a reason to and so in this instance
what Aven story basically done is
traveled around the cosmos and grabbed
all these different people who had
committed some of that most heinous acts
ever because the more intense their
actions were the more regret they felt
for their actions the more intense their
connection to the compassion aspect of
the emotional spectrum would be and so
the idea
when that if they were basically
murderers and they were brought in and
they were inducted into the Indigo tribe
then in turn they would have a far
stronger connection than if it was just
a guy who like cheated on his taxes once
and so because of this this went forward
with the Indigo tribe itself basically
you know operating as this extremely
Emig Matic thing now what this does is
this leads into the chronological first
appearance of the Indigo tribe remember
because of the fact that they were
created by Abin Sur and Abin Sur had
basically died before he was able to
utilize the Indigo tribe what this meant
is they basically just kind of existed
out there and nobody ever knew about
them nobody ever really had a reason to
know about them but the whole basis
behind the Indigo tribe is they are led
by a person named indigo one and she was
actually the very first person to
receive the indigo Lantern ring the
reason for this was because of the fact
that she had killed the daughter of Adam
sors
so Aven Sewer believed if he was able to
basically move her into becoming part of
the Indigo tribe basically feeling
compassion this experiment was
successful for her it could be
successful for virtually anybody else
and so what ended up happening is that
with her becoming the first of the
Indigo sweded up having all these other
members inducted now a lot of these guys
are really for most of these guys we
don't know what their origin stories are
or if they are out there I haven't been
able to find them but the idea is that
somewhere along the line they were just
inducted into the tribe but what ended
up happening is that their introduction
into the Green Lantern mythos as part of
this pre lewd to blackest night
basically came in the aftermath of the
Sinestro Corps war now again if you're
new to this whole thing the Sinestro
Corps war was basically this idea that
thousand s Joe had formed his own
Lantern Corps his own the yellow Lantern
Corps that was predicated on fear and
the idea was to basically just eliminate
the Green Lantern's if they could and if
they couldn't then basically begin
maneuvering the Green Lantern's into the
position to where people stopped viewing
them as a peacekeeping force and started
viewing them as a potential totalitarian
force and the way in which Sinestro did
this was by allowing the yellow lanterns
to kill because remember Green Lantern's
could not kill that was never part of
their role their role was to maintain
peace their role was to use their ring
to basically incapacitate villains and
then bring those villains for trial
not necessarily kill him this in turn
set in motion a set of events where the
Green Lantern Corps now had the ability
to not only kill
members of the Sinestro Corps but anyone
who was an enemy of the guardians of the
universe and the Green Lantern's and
because this was so broad what it
basically meant is people started
looking at the Green Lantern's and
saying well if they kill anybody who's
an enemy of the Green Lantern course and
the guardians of the universe does that
mean that people who like disagree with
them are enemies what defines an enemy
and this is why Sinestro ultimately won
but in the immediate aftermath are
really taking place during this war
between the Green Lantern's in the
Sinestro Corps a couple of them
crash-landed on the planet of the Indigo
tribe now this eventually leads to the
Indigo tribe basically speaking with
them you know talking to them or at
least trying to communicate remember he
had to go try because it's been so far
removed because they were so hidden
their language is not something that can
be deciphered their language as far as
the Green Lantern Corps and the universe
is aware doesn't really exist it's not a
language that anybody understands
outside of the Indigo tribe itself more
so than that one of the reasons why the
Indigo tribe is so significant is
because what they're basically able to
do is mimic the abilities of other
Lantern cores in this instance it's
basically indigo one mimicking the
abilities of a Green Lantern now of
course she also does kind of kills this
Green Lantern essentially smothers him
and it's not really something that's
done as as a heinous act it's done
because of the fact that this Green
Lantern's dying but in return because of
the fact of this ring you know takes off
because this member of the Sinestro
Corps lashes out and basically says I
will be taken down the exact same way
indigo one in turn mimics his powers and
so what she does is basically just
create this massive yellow construct now
this is all we get I mean this was all
that we saw when they first popped up it
was basically a member of the Indigo
tribe using their ring or using their
power for the purpose of duplicating
other members of the lantern cores and
then that was really it and so it was
this huge thing where people were just
like what like what in the world is this
but the cool thing about this is that
the Indigo tribe does not go unanswered
where their origin story didn't appear
until again something like four years
after this initial introduction took
place they have a huge role in blackest
night I mean they are massive in
blackest night as it will actually find
out and really see their full powers put
on display it's one of the reasons why
I'm not really running over everything
they can do I mean I mean there's a few
things in there you know that make them
a little bit different but the full
display of their powers will be brought
to bear when it comes to blackest night
and we'll find out
just how powerful they are but with that
being said guys we're gonna go ahead and
bring this video to an end a pretty
quick one but again not a whole lot to
go with when it comes to the Indigo
tribe they were just designed to be a
really big matic group and again it
wasn't until years after they first
popped up that we actually started
getting some information on them but if
you are new here to comments explain and
make sure you guys hit the sub button to
become part of the Rob port if you guys
enjoyed this video make sure you drop a
like and yeah I will catch you all later
peace
[Music]